being an architect has always been known
as being the jack of all trades
what's going on guys my name is david
thomach and welcome back to the channel
if you're new here firstly thank you so
much for joining me
on this channel we talk about technology
and architecture
as myself personally an entrepreneur a
masters of architecture graduate
and a tech enthusiast so today we're
going to be talking about the five
programs architects
need to know in order to do their job
effectively
we're also going to be looking at them
as a whole
what skills you need to know inside each
of these categories
and how they apply to your actual job so
let's start with number one the most
generic and obvious
you need to know a good 3d modeling
program either
archicad or revit are my two absolute
go-to's
if you don't know either one of these
make sure you start learning them
asap if you know one effectively
and you're an architecture student still
at university take this
freedom and luxury that you have to
learn
the other it is very important that you
know both
so that when it comes time to applying
for a job whatever that firm is using
you know already that skill and you know
how to use that software
the skills are pretty basic here you
need to know everything you need to know
how to document design
you need to know how to draw details in
2d in 3d
it goes on and on because it is a pretty
large chunk of your job
obviously that comes back down to doing
sketch design design development working
drawings construction drawings
everything that's why number one is the
most generic
because it is the program that is
expected
architects know number two photoshop
photoshop is one of adobe's programs
that i recommend today that you learn
because it is a versatile tool to know
there are so many things across the
spectrum of what you do on a day-to-day
basis
that require some basic understanding of
photoshop
no you don't have to go out and be a
complete artist
and know how to draw a full 3d section
and model it
and then render it and do absolutely
everything in photoshop
but most of the skills that you do and
will need to know
are very transferable that
one day you can probably actually do all
this if you needed to
there are three basic skills that you
need to master here one you need to
understand how to add or change
materials and colors
in the photo two you need to know how to
add or remove
people objects or any imperfections in a
photo
and lastly you need to know how to
overlay and create collages and
different
layers in the photoshop program itself
so all of these three skills are very
basic and generic and you can learn them
anywhere on youtube
but these skills form the fundamentals
of what you'll require in practice so
number one to add or change materials
when it comes to doing marketing floor
plans for clients or for the council
it becomes imperative that you
understand how to
add textures and materials to a very
generic floor plan
usually what's produced is a basic black
and white 2d line
floor plan so most of the time you have
to come into photoshop
and add layers and add furniture and do
a little bit of
extra finessing to make these marketing
plans
really stand out yes you can do them in
archicad and revit
but they never look as good referring
back to point number two which is add or
remove people
this one's kind of obvious and generic
for millennials i guess because
we do it very often in photoshopping for
social media
so a lot of people will have that
ability if it isn't even in photoshop
with a third-party app or whatever it is
but it does become very important and
critical
if you're on site taking photos to post
on social media or to try and win some
new clients
and there's i don't know a bucket left
in the bottom corner
or a person that's just sitting in the
background randomly standing there and
you need to get rid of them
to make this shot appealing and
professional it is a very simple skill
that it can be learned very quickly on
photoshop it's a lot easier than you
might think
but it's something that you'll use all
the time
and finally creating collages and
overlaying items is
very basic this is more so used to
create
mood boards and color palettes when you
come to doing interior design
and working with interior architects you
can very easily and quickly
kind of put together a color palette
that can then be presented to somebody
doing the 3d renders or you yourself
doing the 3d renders
so you can kind of visualize and
understand how all these materials work
together
this becomes very good and very useful
for when you actually
need to go to different suppliers and
get physical products so you're not
wasting your time getting 100 different
products
you can simply go and get the top three
or the top five
and then create the palette that you
require one great skill you can
actually do in photoshop very quickly is
learning how to draw the like button
so if you wouldn't mind doing me a favor
smash that like button down below
and if you're really enjoying this video
so far hit the subscribe button to get
more of my content
program number three illustrator
illustrator is another adobe platform
program
that is very simple to actually learn
for what you need to do in an
architectural profession
basically all you need to know is how to
draw lines and fill in some boxes
that's it if you know how to draw a
square and a circle
you're miles above everybody else it
isn't a hard program to learn it's
literally
click pull drag click pull drag and
there you go you've created a circle or
a box
or an arrow but what it is actually used
for in practice and in principle
is many many things so one you'll more
than likely end up designing a logo
on illustrator because it's a vector
graphic program
which means you can shrink your logo to
teeny tiny
or you can blow it up to a billboard and
it will still be pixel perfect
whereas if you create that logo in
photoshop well unfortunately
if you blow it up to what it was i don't
know 10 times its original
size it's going to be very blurry you're
not going to be able to read the text
and it's just going to be a complete
waste
whereas vectors they keep their shape
perfectly the whole time but more so in
practice what you're really going to use
is overlaying diagrams so if you create
an elevation
or a perspective image that needs to
illustrate something on it for example
some landscaping across the front
where the ventilation is how the sun
goes
where people might see some vistas or
how that mass has been manipulated to
create the final product
this is something that you'll use
illustrator to actually overlay that
information
it's a very simple process it takes a
little bit of time
not time to learn but more so time to
actually
do these drawings but once they're
completed
they are very effective communicating
tools you'll then also go ahead and use
illustrator to create little diagrams to
explain different things
so for example you might be explaining
the relationship between the massing of
this property
in relation to the next one there are so
many icons and diagrams that you can
create
that kind of flows into the territory of
a graphic designer
but because we need to communicate our
ideas they can't all be in our head
24 7 it becomes critical that we learn
very quickly how to diagram and
demonstrate
all of these ideas it becomes even more
critical
when you start talking to people who
aren't inside the profession
or who are more used to just reading
plans and don't understand
the architecture as a whole for example
some councils will require and request
that you put together a full
documentation package very similar
to what you do at university to explain
the building the function the form and
how it will sit in relation to its
environment
so this allows people who are coming
straight off the street
especially if it's a very sensitive
project where the community is involved
to understand your vision and hopefully
convince them
and actually get this project built
talking about convincing people
number four rendering software if you're
using archicad or revit
my first recommendation is either
enscape or twin motion
both of them produce phenomenal results
in a very short amount of time
once your model is complete but the
skills you're going to have to master in
3d rendering
is both photo and video there is no
longer a world where photo rendering
is everything you really need to
understand that we're
more of a visual society now especially
with the more social media that we
consume
the more youtube we watch that we become
more and more accustomed to seeing
things
move animate and actually express
emotion
so if you can convey that in a video
that's fantastic
in practice obviously you can use this
to showcase to your clients
clients love seeing 3d renders and 3d
videos especially of their project
especially if it's a mum and dad client
it means their
dream home that they've been dreaming
about thinking about and saving for
their entire life
is finally coming true and they can
visualize it for the first time
ever most people aren't going to be able
to visualize spaces or floor plans
so it's very very important that you
remember
to showcase something in 3d no matter
what your skills and ability is
it just gets the picture and the point
across so like i mentioned in my last
video
councils also require a lot of detail
and understanding of projects
especially if they have to communicate
it to the community for something that's
a very sensitive project it's important
to get
feedback and information from the
community and the council
during the review and the da process
that that you can actually
learn what they want in order to make
sure this project is viable and
constructable
it's no good building and designing the
absolute best thing
ever in the world if it's going to get
rejected by bureaucracy
and finally videos are just good to use
as a marketing tool either be it selling
yourself
or selling the actual property before
it's built you'd be surprised how many
people will watch a video go
wow that is amazing and absolutely where
i want to live for the rest of my life
or work for the rest of my life
and here's my deposit let's get going
and finally
the fifth program you have to learn is
excel in excel
there is an abundance of things you can
know and do
and it's more so a financial program
than anything else
but it's good to know the very basic
formulas in excel
and understand the principles of how it
works depending on where you work
and what kind of practice you work at
many companies are still using excel for
their time
sheets and various other documentation
a lot of builders end up using it for
their gantt charts
processing how they will actually plan
out the building and stage out the
building
and then you're going to have to
understand how to use it for variations
and time delays
and documentation so it becomes a very
good
filing and documenting tool and
basically a lifesaver
when you have to do a lot of math it's
definitely an out of the box program
that
i recommend learning but it is something
that you will have to know or eventually
just get
accustomed to because let me give you an
example in practice if you're on site
a builder has issued you a variation and
you haven't tracked it properly it's
gone unnoticed
they can easily assume that the
variation has been accepted
and continue building that section of
the building
now if you've missed that variation
if you haven't tracked it properly if
the information hasn't been conveyed
properly it has been filed and
documented properly
this could cost hundreds of thousands of
dollars so
it's critical that every bit of
information during construction
is documented and filed properly and
excel is just one of the tools that
you're going to be using for that whole
period of construction there's only one
real shortfall with excel though and
that's the fact
you can't really draw a realistic like
button
you're gonna have to just hit that one
down there make it turn blue and help
this video with the algorithm
so more people get this advice and learn
the top five programs architects need to
know anyway that's all from me today
guys thank you so much for watching
if you enjoyed the video make sure you
smash that like button just below
make it turn blue and help this video
with the algorithm
the more likes it gets the more it gets
spread to the youtube community and the
more people that will see it
so i'd really appreciate it if you hit
the like button if you enjoyed it make
sure you also smash that subscribe
button to get more of my content
usually it's every monday that i upload
but this week i'm trying to push out
three videos in one week anyway wish me
luck
and i'll see you next time